meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
hier gibt es einige
Entschuldigung wir leben in der
Demokratie Freunde
lass bitte jeden Redner Ausreden und wir
reden hier vom bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten Mittelmeer Respekt
bitte gell ich kann Ihnen nur sagen Haut
selber ab wer so agiert ist kein
Demokrat für unser Land von solchen
Leuten grenzen wir uns ab und zwar
grundlegend
wer will sich die bürgerliche Mitte
treffen und sie hat sich im Münchner
Merkur gerade von solchen abgegrenzt die
schreien und andere angreifen ich will
nur eines sagen die bürgerliche Mitte
hat nichts mit AFD die bürgerliche Mitte
hat nichts mit an die Demokraten zu tun
die sind nicht willkommen ich sagte es
ganz klar die AFD bewegt nichts sie
bringt nur Schaden für unser Land und
warum wollen wir sie nicht und trotzdem
bin ich da und meine und unsere Meinung
an der Stelle zu sagen wer glaubt andere
nieder schreien zu können diese Zeiten
gab es früher in Deutschland die wollen
wir aber nicht die Demokraten sind
stärker als die an die Demokraten liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde meine Damen und
Herren
hier sind Landwirte hier sind
Waldbesitzer hier ist Mittelstand wir
sind sogar Vertreter der ampelparteien
da was ich sehr mutig und begrüßenswert
finde um ein klares Statement zu geben
ein Statement gegen dieses neue
heizgesetz nicht etwa gegen die
Demokratie sondern gegen dieses
heizgesetz viele Bürger sind besagt dass
ihr Wohlstand jede verdiente
Lebensleistung bedroht ist ja für den
Klimaschutz aber nein zu diesem
heizungsgesetz meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
Klimaschutz ist wichtig aber er muss mit
und darf nicht gegen die Bürger gemacht
werden gerade die Grünen und das kann
man sagen treiben die Dinge so weit mit
brachialkur voran und zwar nur mit
Ideologie ohne Pragmatismus ohne
Vernunft und deswegen das klare Signal
diese Politik der Grünen darf nicht die
Mehrheit in Deutschland werden meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren wer soll
das alles in der Kürze der Zeit
eigentlich bezahlen entweder gehen die
Bürger oder der Staat in den Ruinen und
ich sage euch eins ich habe keine Lust
Seite an Seite mit den Grünen in die
Pleite zu gehen darauf habe ich keine
Lust das kann uns Erfolg nicht wollen
was brauchen wir jetzt
dieses Gesetz soll in die Schublade wir
brauchen für die wärmewende was anders
Anreize statt Verbote Anreize statt
Strafen völlige technologieoffenheit
andere Übergangsfristen statt im
nächsten Jahr zu beginnen mindestens
fünf Jahre und statt den letzten Einbau
für drei Jahre zu ermöglichen für zehn
Jahre und diese Regel mit den
80-jährigen muss weg ich finde jeder der
Rentner ist sollte von dieser Pflicht
befreit werden meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das für ein Angebot
dass wir gerne machen
und wenn es nicht alle hier tun wir tun
es schon in Bayern wir reichen die Hand
wir wollen etwas erreichen und wir
werden uns und das zum Schluss auch
gegen diese ständige verbotskultur die
überall diskutiert wird ich sag so jeder
soll essen was er will aber eine
zwangshafte veganisierung Deutschlands
und Bayerns macht keinen Sinn ein Leben
und nicht schweinbraten macht möglich
sein aber nicht sinnvoll wir wollen auch
in der Zukunft essen können was wir
wollen meine Damen und Herren und uns
das nicht vorschreiben lassen
wir sind das schönste Land in
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren mit
Abstand
Werder gegen pfeift der gehört nicht zu
uns nach Bayern meine Damen und Herren
das muss ich schon mal sagen wer gegen
Bayern der braucht ja nicht da sein ja
und Bayern soll so bleiben und Bayern
soll von meinem Land bleiben in dem
normale Leute ihre Zukunft sich noch
genauso leisten können und dafür treten
wir einen dafür arbeite ich und ich
sag's zusammenfassend ja zum Klimaschutz
aber nein zu diesem ideologisch können
inhaltsgesetz herzlichen Dank alles Gute
gott schütze Bayern danke schön
[Applaus]
Herr Professor Richter dieser Auftritt
wurde massiv kritisiert von Grünen und
SPD aber auch bei Twitter ganz intensiv
noch mehr der seines Stellvertreters
Hubert Aiwanger von den Freien Wählern
der gesagt hat die große schweigende
Mehrheit des Landes müsste sich die
Demokratie zurückholen viele haben
gesagt das ist maximaler Populismus
aller AFD bewegt sich hier die CDU in
diesem Falle die CSU die Union
vielleicht auch im Ganzen auf einem
populistischen Pfad den man so noch
nicht kannte
na ich würde sagen ja sie tut es sie
bewegt sich auf einen populistischen
Pfad aber den kannte man schon also von
Söder ist es bekannt dass er immer mal
wieder in Richtung Populismus
getreten ist und da gewissermaßen
Neuland betreten hat das haben wir schon
im letzten Wahlkampf gesehen ja wo also
auch von asyltourismus sprach und
ähnlichem also er hat sich dann auch das
AFD Vokabular gewisser Weise angeeignet
und insofern tut er das jetzt wieder
also gut das ist bayerischer Wahlkampf
aber es gibt auch für diesen Wahlkampf
argumentative Grenzen und die
überschreitet der an der Stelle ganz
eindeutig und Aiwanger in der Tat hat
AFD sprechen von sich gegeben das heißt
genau die Rhetorik die die AFD eben auch
immer benutzt also insofern ist das
schon bedenklich und ich finde es auch
ähm sehr bedenklich dass eben gegen
diesen Gesetzesentwurf der ja erst mal
beraten werden soll auf diese Art und
Weise Polemik betrieben wird das muss
man ja erst mal argumentativ auseinander
nehmen bevor man so eine Art von Polemik
von sich gibt also insofern müssen wir
uns da auf einiges im bayerischen
Wahlkampf gefasst machen das war schon
sehr stark ja es interessant aber jetzt
will ich schon noch mal ein bisschen
weiten auf die Union insgesamt die Union
fährt ja eine Kampagne gegen den ich
zitiere das Heizungs Hammer und der
Thüringer Chef ich gucke gerade noch mal
hatte mir das eben raus mit der
Thüringer Chef der CDU der hat sogar vor
der Energie Stasi gewarnt also ist das
ja ein Jargon der hier aus Bayern kommt
der doch auch in der Union im Moment
zumindest in Teilen wiederfindet oder
nicht
ja und da muss man eigentlich sein
Entsetzen Ausdruck verleihen weil diese
Art von
Verunglimpfungen das ist ja immer eine
Art von Polemik die ist eigentlich nicht
zuträglich die ist in der Tat einfach
populistisch und damit ist sie eben
nicht argumentativ und klärt die
Bevölkerung auch nicht auf sondern
wickelt sie nur auf also das auch dass
man das ganze Ding heizungsgesetz nennt
ist ja schon eine Verkürzung weil es ein
Gebäude Energiegesetz genannt werden
muss und auch ein solches ist also
insofern die
Sprache die
Rhetorik die da verwendet wird ist ein
Stück der das Populismus und das
bedeutet eben man ist weg von einer
argumentativen Auseinandersetzung
erklärt die Bevölkerung nicht auf
sondern man winkelt sie nur auf und das
finde ich ganz furchtbar und natürlich
als Politikwissenschaftler versuchen wir
das zu erklären und auch unseren
Entsetzen darüber ausdrucken verleihen